lost to Trump in um 2016 what in your
view would happen if he were to be
reelected I think it would be the end of
our country as we know it let's talk
about the fact that it was the greatest
economy that we' have seen in modern
American history how about the fact that
there were no major new Wars this is the
fundamental problem you guys can comment
below and let me know if you disagree in
attacking Donald Trump people not even
Republicans you're looking at right now
the approval among black Americans
Hispanics people under 30 they know they
don't have a leg to stand on if they say
the e om is better off right now under
Biden or that we are better off with our
International relationships under Biden
they know it's not true